en el video anterior vimos Cómo calcular
el tiempo que tarda en despegar este
avión
a380 teniendo como datos la velocidad de
despegue y la
aceleración
ahora lo que quisiera yo saber es qué
tan larga debe ser la pista para que
este avión pueda despegar lo que es una
pregunta muy importante si ustedes
quieren construir una pista que permita
que al menos este tipo de aviones a 380
puedan despegar Cuál será la longitud
mínima para esta pista bueno Nosotros
sabemos que el
desplazamiento es la multiplicación o
bueno va ser el resultado de multiplicar
la velocidad por el tiempo pero en este
caso nuestra velocidad no es constante
nuestra velocidad está cambiando este
durante el tiempo entonces no podríamos
usar este dato
directamente sin
embargo nosotros tenemos esta
aceleración pero esta acelera
tiene la particularidad de que es
constante y cuando tenemos una
aceleración constante si y solo si
tenemos aceleración constante entonces
podemos encontrar o calcular algo
llamado velocidad promedio
o average en inglés por eso es esta a la
velocidad promedio entonces cómo
calculamos la velocidad promedio nuestra
vad promedio que sigue siendo un vector
va a ser igual a el promedio de mi
velocidad
final
menos mi velocidad inicial y bueno como
son dos elementos o dos cantidades Pues
el promedio de estos dos va a ser
dividido va a ser dividir esta operación
este resultado entre dos Entonces mi
velocidad
promedio tengo que bueno la velocidad
final la encontramos por aquí 78 m por
segundo
78 metros por segundo menos mi velocidad
inicial bueno partimos del entendido de
que de está desde cer0 desde que está
detenida entonces
-0 entre 2 Así que mi velocidad promedio
es 78 / 2 Resulta ser 39 m por segundo
Entonces ahora sí con este dato de la
velocidad
promedio lo puedo
multiplicar con eh el la el cambio en el
tiempo y así entonces puedo calcular el
desplazamiento Si queremos ver esto o
entenderlo de otra manera vamos a ver
una forma un poco más
vamos a graficar aquí eh la velocidad
con respecto al tiempo Este es mi eje de
velocid perdón de tiempo Este es mi eje
de velocidad y si yo tengo una
aceleración constante Este voy a tener
esta gráfica más o
menos de esta manera va a ser una
aceleración constante por lo que se va a
incrementar así más o menos en este
ángulo esto es una línea recta Aunque mi
pulso no es lo mejor esta mañana
entonces si yo
tengo que este inicio desde cero y aquí
mi tiempo de despegue es 78 segundos en
este punto es cuando mi avión tiene la
velocidad suficiente para despegar y
vamos a ver que también pues desde
eh la
velocidad si comienzo desde cero y
alcanzo mi velocidad de despegue que es
78 m por
segundo Pues aquí también se va a
alcanzar en este punto Y a partir de
aquí bueno el ón ya despega del
suelo si yo eh calculara el área bajo
esta curva si yo calculara esta área va
a resultar que esta área va a ser igual
a la distancia que se necesita recorrer
para que este avión pueda despegar en
otro
video vamos a ver eh Cuál es el porqué
de esta gráfica al menos darles una idea
un poco más general este de bueno por
qué el área bajo la curva de la
aceleración esto es la
aceleración me va a ser igual a la
distancia eh Cuando yo estoy trabajando
con la velocidad promedio que recordamos
bueno calculamos la velocidad promedio
es la mitad o el punto intermedio entre
mi velocidad inicial y mi velocidad
final que viene siendo más o menos por
acá si yo uso esta velocidad promedio
este dato hasta esta el tiempo necesario
para El despegue si Yo calculo el área
bajo esta curva o bajo esta línea de la
velocidad promedio va a ser exactamente
el la misma área que la que se encuentra
con esta aceleración desde una velocidad
que está cambiando desde cer0 hasta la
velocidad final y es por eso que bueno
esta velocidad promedio me sirve para
calcular el desplazamiento o la
distancia ahora regresando a los números
tenemos que entonces
que tengo mi desplazamiento que es igual
mi velocidad prom medio la acabo
calcular a
39 Met sobre segundo el desplazamiento
en el
tiempo lo calculé
a
78 segundos y saco mi calculadora hago
mis
operaciones
por
78 y Esto me da igual a
342 aquí escribo Entonces mi
desplazamiento es igual a
342 Aquí estos segundos se van me quedan
metros Así que la distancia para que
este avión pueda despegar la pista debe
de medir más de 3000 m que es más
de 3
km para que este avión
pueda volar para que pueda despegar lo
que encuentro en verdad
fascinante